thank you to manscaped and Shopify for
sponsoring the channel this week more on
them after the
reaction a little Gremlin child I
am yeah a little bit of Yoda as well
actually have no idea what the Gremlins
are like but that's what they look like
the only thing I know about Gremlins is
that oh do they have yours I think so
this is what I know every person
references Gremlins for one reason
the first movie and the second movie are
completely different
genre I don't know what genre either of
them are I don't either I I know people
whip this one out around Christmas oh is
that true yeah all right give it to the
Jew then Ron joxy in the house Jo C we
are watching Gremlins the first one
we've never seen it we have no idea what
we're in for but Jingle Bells Are
Ringing they might be I might be wrong I
don't
know we'll see it's not a Christmas
movie uh if you guys are excited about
this like the video comment subscribe
hit that Bell for notification purposes
or for Christmas purposes always for
Christmas there's Bells with Christmas
right Silver Bells to denote Christmas
time in the city all the bells for
Christmas or silver in the song they are
is not true there's a lot of different
kinds of bells oh oh Silver
Bell Silver Bell you much better voice
than I do if you want all of the singing
and all of the shenanigans then be super
sexy become a patron where you can um
have a full length Reaction watch along
where you syn up with your own copy it
wasn't even there and I did it and I did
it that's where the super sexy rejects
are that's where John and Greg cover
several shows exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
Purge I just purged all that goodness
out are you ready for the I'm so ready
for this I'm hanging on the edge of my
seat okay let's do it also guys roxxy's
new film always Lola just dropped on VOD
it's been getting great reviews we
really appreciate if you guys check it
out and if you do come on back in the
comments and show her some love let her
know it's Warner Brothers part of the
amtp now having a deal with SAG we love
to see it last long
[Music]
last huh where do this movie take place
let me introduce myself Pelzer is the
name ran Pelzer that's me there on the
corner that's me in the
corner that's me in the street lights
well nobody's got a story like this one
okay it all started here in Chinatown
we're in Chinatown I was hitting the
shops trying to move a little Merchant
find a present for my kid I tried this
one Place Chinatown
USA just so you know I thought this
movie was animated so I'm all I'm tapped
already all surprises this is your
grandfather's store yeah okay I wonder
you got to drag people off the street
the audio of this sounds like they're
playing a movie it's going to pull out
from the TV any moment that's what it
sounds like look around see if there's
something you
like see anything you like
[Laughter]
Halloween and I'm sure many other things
so we got to assume we're in New York
cuz Yankees yeah and Chinatown
interesting artifacts here but there's
one thing you don't have I'm an inventor
I made this the bathroom buddy oh
invention of the century friends it
eliminates the need to carry heavy
luggage and things when you travel oh
you got yourself your toothbrush you got
yourself toothpick you got toenail
Clippers you got
not all you do is you take your
toothbrush out and you push this butt oh
Jeepers ran Pelzer fantastic ideas for
fantastic world I make the illogical
logical bars I can get them by the Dozen
if you like it reminds you when people
go on Shark Tank and the pitch goes
wrong like it's no problem it's fine
this is the direct predecessor to that
this guy's going to go start Shark Tank
any minute now it's Mark Cuban
yep
what is it a gremlin
m a m yeah what's he doing singing a the
voice of a thein I got to have him he's
incredible tell you what I'll do I'll
give you $100 for him damn no look I've
got to have him it's a present for my
son for Christmas I'll give you $200
what was was your
criteria with M comes much
responsibility I cannot sell him at any
price not even to
Spider-Man wait outside a moment I'll be
right out I'm going to haggle with my
dad he's going to steal the M my grandpa
whoever here it is oh what about your
grandfather we need the money now come
on you want it or not I want
it take my money kid that cross fade
back in the 80s there's three rules
you've got to follow keep them out of
the light especially sunlight it'll kill
them oh no and keep him away from water
he's a vampire but the most important
rule no matter how much he cries no
matter how much he begs never feed him
after midnight whoa I know people like
that when can you start feeding them
again because it's always after midnight
somewhere it's a really fair question
wow Rock and Ricky Rialto that is some
Indiana Jones font Rialto the voice of
Kingston Falls USA hey
Christmas
Ste Spielberg look
out did you know that
nope Jesus kid oh Phoebe katees damn all
right all
right and Hoy Aon I love ho axon so much
thought I'd be seeing you about this
time H what the hell is
this what are you doing in there don't
ask I'm
Undercover
[Music]
come on you hunka
junk okay Jerry gold smith because this
is a tune yeah man Jerry Goldsmith got
Classics under his belt love to see a
jeude doing a Christmas movie music yeah
man it's going to be the the most Jewish
Christmas movie you've ever
seen happening there it's got to melt
some of that snow Kathleen Kennedy
Kathleen that is wild hey man she's
produced a lot of classics all right
people go hard on her but she's produced
a lot of gems pretty much late for work
as it is goddamn fign ca he always frees
up on you that guy Dick Miller see that
plow 15 years old hasn't given me a
day's trouble in 15 years you know why
Kentucky Harvester Harvester I want to
keep my job I really think I should be
going now hey how's that comic strip of
yours coming I expect to see you in a
funny as any day now with smiling Jack
and little abna yeah oh well Mr fman
they don't run those Comics anymore
what so you've never had the privilege
of having to get snow off your car I
mean I've had to you know defrost a car
once or twice on trips but not like
frequently as part of my life growing up
imagine going to high school and every
day just have you have to start the day
y you got to heat the car 20 minutes
early ouch written by Chris
Columbus this is interesting he started
trying to write home alone and then
accidentally wrote this it
bunny what's up pup oh damn it's a good
quick change what do you know about
quick changes when you are have been a
warm weather man your whole life you
don't know everything I am wearing a
unitard under this outfit right now this
feeling when you walk in and your hands
are like thawing out still and you have
to start using them your fingers are all
still like slow and numb you sign this
petition yeah sure what's it for what's
it for we're trying to have dory's Pub
declared to land Mark Mrs deagle trying
to take his lease away uh-oh yeah she
says it's a dive a public nuisance
that's what my dad proposed to my mom
you know that's where everybody's dad
proposed to their mom cross your teeth
a and look deep into my
eye W she's immediately giving the witch
from Wizard of Oz energy good morning
Mrs deagle what's good about it I knew
it pretty dog too she's the wicked witch
and she's eban or Scrooge 60
[Music]
80 great music choice Mrs
deagle I just wanted to let you know
that Joe got himself another job my
husband Joe Harris and I've taken up
some sewing on side Mrs Harris what are
you trying to
tell it's a great reaction off screen it
neither one of us will be paid for 2
weeks just give us a little more time
the bank and I have the same purpose in
life to make money not to support a lot
of dead beats but miss deagle it's
Christmas M deagle it's Christmas hey I
wrote this
movie in a dream how how did you do that
it's telepathy
Psychiatry this is what's left of my
imported Bavarian snowman your dog broke
it this morning I'm terribly sorry just
tell me how much I owe you I'll be more
than happy to I don't want money fix it
I I want your dog she is literally the
Witch and your pretty dog too H I'll
take him to the kennel they'll put him
to sleep it'll be quick and painless
compared to what I could do to him
for for messing up your decorative
snowman then he'll get what he deserves
uhoh a slow painful death maybe I'll put
him in my spin dryer on high heat
wowee no doggo
[Music]
damn
it damn she deserves it American hero
that dog Bonnie wouldn't have hurt you
Mrs deagle honestly excuses excuses
you're just like your father I've
listened to his miserable excuses for 10
years the loser I'll get
you most unusual you putts yeah you
putts been a long time since I've heard
someone called a putts it isn't Captain
clipon guess who almost appli for
unemployment today I give up you but Mr
Corbin had second thoughts clipon yeah
he clipped his tie on right when he got
to work
oh good catch well Merry Christmas to
you too excuse me Mr jnes this guy was
like an every 80s movie yeah for real
you're practically supporting your whole
family the world's changing Peltzer you
got to change with it you got to be
tough be a man you haven't seen my new
apartment I haven't seen your old
apartment
we're talking cable can't we have dinner
tomorrow night I'm working we're talking
cable why don't you tell dor you're sick
you can't dock your
pay fre sucks yeah why are you around
any of these people Billy is that you
yeah Mom it's me them swords going to
come in handy
later hi sweetie a do you need any help
um yeah you could do the eggs look at
all those ons what do you think she's
making like a stew with eggs or like a
meatloaf
maybe what
the oh it's his dad makes all those
inventions ah don't be a putts man dad's
machines they work so well the first
couple of weeks and Mrs deagle called
again this afternoon so did Mrs
smeele is it like every time they open
the door invent some to hold those
swords up
better thanks Dad you're gonna like this
what is it a bird cage it's a bread case
it's a puppy isn't it yeah it is I can
tell it's a new this dad is so sweet
yeah dim the lights dad what does it do
glowin the dark it's important trust me
I'm not messing with you is this a
horror movie I'm not sure maybe a
little
damn it's your new BET huh come on
Bonnie be a good dog yeah don't don't
mul this
creature so is he going to name him
Gremlin I don't
know you're
kidding maybe it'll be like some
prejudiced slang they use for the MOG
one looks like a Furby yeah I don't know
why I thought they were like green or
something
[Music]
cute has it got a name Dad yeah m is
word it's a Scottish band I just call
him Gizmo Gizmo I've heard that
Gizmo hey you got get a picture taken
smile oh no the flash one 2
3 what happened he hates Bright Lights
yeah can't feed him after midnight don't
don't give him any water to drink and
whatever you do don't give him a bath
and probably the most important thing
don't ever feed him after midnight I
like how he's talking as if he like
knows what he's talking about what do
you think to De with the water thing is
though how you going to clean them you
know various
acids so they must have designed Furbies
after this right did you have one of
those no but I mean it was they were
ubiquitous I spent time with many
Furbies I never had one of my
[Music]
own he's so
cute I just do not know where we're
going in terms of is should I be
prepared to be sad oh jeez dude be
careful
is there water in there sure hope
not oh damn
it did he say bright light yeah but also
he's got to wash him off from being in
the
trash all
right oh what is that has he got like a
little scrape yeah he bandag him
up oh little guy try not to R much okay
a how do you think they're doing that
with him with the oh it's probably some
kind of puppet I don't know where we're
at with like radio control technology
but yeah there's got to be puppeteering
going on for
[Music]
sure but she said they work for the
first couple weeks
remember hey a damn it oh my God oh my
God
is there extra water going through there
what a fun character tra for a character
yeah Christ jeez
kid wow one orange did all that just
brought in your Christmas Tre other ones
what happened is that Corey for sure you
know you should just buy orange juice
and cars it's a lot
easier see it
works
jees dude that must be the earliest I've
ever seen
Cory yeah is that not a bright light
though guess not bright
enough what's that yeah I'll show you
got so many cool posters dad gave it to
me NE what's his name his name's Gizmo
giz it's like everybody's treating it
like it's normal like neat yeah like
your universe is are weird pets common
[Music]
now watch Pete maybe he'll s he's very
natural makes me kind of sad I sat with
him for like an hour a CP few years ago
interviewing him can I hold him sure I
don't see why not he seems to like
you the water the
water oh God oh God
no why is he making that noise
a pick him up get him out of the water
right what was that nice little Dutch
tilt I don't
know oh it's one of those things from
Star Trek it's a it's a trible the
trouble with tribles the best episodes
ever goes the second
one multiplies so they reproduce if you
water
[Music]
them oh my God this is like little holes
in his back
why are they picking him up why are they
just letting him suffer
there
damn this is some interesting effects
does the reproduce and
[Music]
die the little guys little nose one 2
three four five new ones can I keep yeah
hey look at that one's got a cute little
stripe on its
head ow I mean don't you think this is
incredible prob is neat I'm
[Music]
[Laughter]
serious there's a problem with the magai
yeah what's that well it multiplies with
water
what oh no oh no Donkey Kong you know
it's funny the new ones aren't like
Gizmo the one with the seems to be the
leader you know what I'll bet every kid
in America would like to have one of
these oh Jesus
uh-oh you chewing tobacco over there
what is that think about it the Pelzer
pit it's good alliteration this could
really be the big
one the family pictures on the wall that
was so common then I love the set
decoration in
this
[Music]
what do you think dog's dead oh God I
hope not I'm worried one of them's going
to like go raid the fridge or something
I still know the
tone
yes like are we expecting comedy or
horror
yes oh jeez oh good dog is still alive I
think we're expecting a little of
both poor dog another minute and he
would have been a
doxic no wow look all I know is that I'm
positive that I closed and locked the
door well Dad then how else did she get
to him oh oh Billy we can't Point any
fingers not even at Mrs deagle no a
hydrodynamic
spatular oh my
God they're such a cute couple though
cuz she finds it endearing her life must
be so inconvenient yeah but I'm sure she
also just lives him cuz he's sweet and
all of a sudden there were five new ones
like this
one now watch this no no what dude
[Music]
no it's got to be odd having people just
like drip water on you and induce labor
it's it feels mean I keep one of these
here run some test on them yeah I think
I could SP only one multipli this time
cuz one drop of water I guess so yeah oh
they miss each other I feel like it's
it's like dividing almost not multiply I
don't know it feels like every time they
get more a little more evil right time
to go home now hey how about one more
beer no it's getting late and one more
beer I help you clean up this mess no
thanks though it'll be
[Music]
okay going home oh oh
yeah he drives
tractor
Gremlins hey
you got to watch out from the foreigners
cuz they plant Gremlins in their
Machinery that's the same Gremlins
brought down our planes in the big one
what World War II good old
WWII what do you know man I don't think
it's such a good idea that you drive
home why don't you walk home you know
Katie I think maybe I'll walk home yes
that's a good idea he's been like that
ever since he lost his job he's like a
lot of people around here I just want
somebody to listen oh yeah especially
around the holidays why is that that's
when a lot of people get really
depressed yep that's funny you know
because I always thought everyone was
happy during the holidays common
misconception well everybody else is
opening up their presents they're
opening up their R oh did she did she
say wrists yep did you ever get
depressed on Christmas I don't celebrate
Christmas what your hind or something no
I just don't like to what's not to like
I mean it's a lot of fun you know oh
Hindus don't celebrate Christmas
Washington's birthday or Thanksgiving
and nobody cares but say hate Christmas
and everybody makes you feel like you're
a leper Story of My Life
babe I bet she lost somebody on
Christmas this right I mean I was just
wondering um if you're not doing
anything this Thursday night maybe you'd
like to uh go out on a date no I'd love
to you'll be happy this Christmas we can
talk about it you know on the phone and
kind of square everything away
nice Billy no you hang up that was so
effing cute
Purge wow they are quite quite lovely
I'm so happy with that lover of Love
shipper ships their chemistry is
delightful it really that was that was
precious me no no this is not going to
[Music]
hurt I hope it's not water there you oh
you're taking it out what what's up with
you I don't just looks like it hurts and
the needle is so big compared to his
little tiny arm where they come having
fun fun pretty neat fun neat neat you
were right about the words hey but I was
also kind of
right what is with you guys how about
shutting up for a change okay already
fed you what did you feed them not after
midnight it's not 12:00 yet all right
keep an eye on him GID I'll be back in a
second everybody gets a sandwich here we
go oh boy may you guys will be
quiet oh my God this is like watching
denior
eat what he's hungry it's almost
midnight
was that just a brain on the table wait
did he tell him don't feed them after
midnight it's like after 2 a.m.
now that clock is right oh no he's
leaving the sandwich thing there he's
going to eat
it you just leave a
sandwich just like out I only had like a
two bites out of it like out on the desk
there oh look at his sleepy
face so adorable
[Music]
mom yeah Mom could you come up here
please oh
my what what is that is
that then I want you to bring that
vacuum cleaner
upstairs what what are they those are
gremlins did you feed them after
midnight well I gave them some chicken
but I made sure that
it oh is your clock broken ug I thought
so cuz when we went to the other place
it was 2: in the
morning Mom what's going on here
M pupil stage like a butterfly right
this is a cocoon and inside he's going
through
changes good they're going to turn into
[Music]
Gremlins
hello it's a good idea oh my God I like
that she's always trying to use stuff no
I'm I'm sure it works fine I was just
out in the back porch for a second the
convention's
great yeah it's a time machine from The
Time Machine actually the competition is
a oh damn in Forbidden Planet this is a
little more advanced than I expected I
Wasing myself some really neat things
yeah this must be so dank in
here must smell so fleshy and moist
trippy moist trippy moist gooey moist
where's that psychotic canine of yours
still hiding under the counter he's on
vacation better keep him behind locked
doors because if I catch him he's in for
slow death oh no she's going to find the
grand she going to catch a m Doo you got
a human heart has he got a human heart
where do you see this roll 10 you got a
human heart how many times a minute does
a gremlin heart
beat
two oh oh God oh
God
woo the
light oh remember when I told you I was
like I I thought they were green yeah
maybe they
[Music]
are oh
Gizmo he's hiding in a
helmet oh it's like alien this movie is
making me a little anxious and I'm like
this got to be like a real old
educational film no I just mean this
movie the movie Gremlin because I'm
unsure on what's Happening yeah like I
mean I get what's happening obviously
but I'm like what how nervous should I
be yeah exactly how nervous should I be
come on
now hey you're not still angry about
that little blood test are you come on
out take a bite are you a Snickers
person I like a Snickers it's not my
favorite candy but I like his
yum yum y
hey now don't you feel better huh you
going bite your hand no you B it
off Mr Hansen is he dead yes or no I
think he's got a stump
hand oh no he
did oh no he stabbed him with the
needle oh
[Music]
no
e loss of Innocence eats the Apple L of
Innocence what the he's eating
glass or he's conducting an
experiment ah damn
it like if you're him what's grunning
through your mind
like
all kinds of
stuff it's fun the way they're using
like physical elements to communicate
the movement so they don't have to do as
much like Direct on screen it's like he
moves like there's like a flying little
cotton balls and stuff dude there's so
many upstairs oh no oh jeez
dude if you harm one hair on Gizmo's
body I'm so sad right now yeah it's
animal
cruelty
oh very deliberate use of these
like Dutch angle
pans
what they're getting dank up
here it's the opposite of trippy moist
hot box in the Attic dry heat dry smoke
drippy
moist oh my God the
cocoons but where is Gizmo are you okay
where are you on the hatch get out of
the
house oh yeah Gizmo is still in the dumb
waiter seven
night do see what I
see I
see ah man don't ruin the groove SES
it's okay it's okay Do You Hear What I I
hear Do You Hear What I Hear
I should learn the
words maybe one of his inventions is
going to save her life oh like the
swords good
call come on Mom you got this jab jab
yeah or maybe he's going to have the
bathroom buddy on him oh yeah someone's
getting spray with toothpaste yeah
shaving cream or
something get it Mama
kill her mommy don't let him live so
it's like a horror comedy right
[Music]
now y Gremlin
yep what did they do in World War II I
don't know they must have just been
inside all the Machinery eating on wires
and
stuff oh
nice nice wa oh my God
Carnage yes she got a
shield it's like Good China
looking oh my god get a get a match on
that flamethrower that oh oh wow oh fit
in the microwave
oh oh
yeah trust that stocking it's in the
stocking but maybe it's Gizmo maybe he's
hiding but based on the sounds I don't
think so oh you're right though that
would be more clever this movie feels
clever just don't want her to skewer
poor
[Music]
guy oh no oh robit justn cool toy oh the
eyes nice nice with the eyes glowing red
eyes it's like a rabbit animal has
anybody made a move about a killer
Christmas
tree run forest this is a great premise
for your strange holiday horror
movie gra the
sword right in the fire Mom are you all
right I think so
we whoa oh my God the rest of his body
go he chopped his head off oh there you
go there you
go
[Music]
W oh it's a laundry shoot I thought it
was a dumb waiter the question is
totally without
meaning pardon me sir stuff that is
Forbidden Planet right I don't know or
is it Lost in Space I've never seen
Forbidden Planet it's a movie yeah it's
like an old sci-fi movie with the famous
robot I never saw it it's fun to stay at
the Y MCA of Kingston Falls stripe is
staying at the
YMCA a of kings and Falls yeah he's just
going to get himself clean have a good
meal and do whatever he feels which is
probably eating somebody young man don't
go looking for trouble I said young man
when you're uh when there's uh the the
bubble I don't know we'll figure it out
something on the double
yeah that'll disconcert you oh
yeah wow
ouch no was thato no that was stripe
what happens when stripe goes in the
water I don't know but it's a lot of
water and it's
chlorinated
whoa the Lazarus Pit but do you think
that he you can replicate once you're
already uh Gremlin I've been wondering
that I've also been wondering what we're
going to do with the rest of the movie
We're making an army of Gremlins it's
either a giant Gremlin or an army of
Gremlins maybe they skip cute phase and
just go straight to being evil little
monsters right Hunters them little
monsters Lady Gaga hey what are these
little uh Gremlins come from H my father
gave me one as a present a PR the always
give you uh vicious little monsters for
a present no no they don't start out at
vicious at first it's just like one of
his inventions could you dim the lights
in here please go ahead Brent dim the
lights come on Brent oh it's that guy
there's another that oh my God was that
Mike from Breaking Bad Mike man trout
really yeah just like super young I
think that's wild he used to be a young
man oh no no I love how jittery they are
a little stop motion
no I wouldn't mind if she
gets right M oh no that's not the that's
eag no I like her Larry nothing bad
going to happen to Larry is it she when
you quit messing with the TV well he he
has experience with the Gremlins he said
that they didn't took down the big one
yeah he's going to come in handy I can't
get a damn thing on his where are you
going I'm going to check the antenna
maybe the damn thing blew down he got a
Nixon poster
our place they made it look cold somehow
what the hell is that what we got Mr FL
get him you got this babe Nobody messes
with Dick
Miller
whoa
whoa not in my back
hoe such imps I actually really dig the
music in this yeah it's like wacky but
still kind of super quirky yeah but it's
like just
right
oh it must have been so fun to shoot
this scene it is crazy oh
yeah he knows I told you he
knew he's probably been waiting for this
day of vindication he had Gremlin
PTSD patriotic little F lady waving a
flag and everything yep that's what
Gizmo's all about America might tear
your arm off you want me to put the
cuffs on him it is him that is wild look
at that face oh my God I never would
have pulled that yeah what what happed
something about a a snowplow freak
accident it's a creature the creatures
are making it look like an AC guys
believe him go on
home the fireplace and open your
Christmas presents okay Gizmo was his
Christmas present oh so all this
happened with in like a
day no buddy bill dollar bill his name
is dollar bill that's what I would name
a cat I could this music would be good
like bedtime music for me
yes we'll get you the vinyl of the
soundtrack yeah I kind of want that it
like makes me feel like loopy like off
to La La Land yeah I want you
no
yep they are they I would feel bad for
her if she wasn't the living
[Music]
worst
jeez did homie build this did pops build
this oh my God
[Music]
what
no you you saw one of them messing with
the wiring yeah that was hysterical oh
my God that was
incredible oh jeez Jesus Frank that's
Dave Myers he does Santa every year okay
I was like this is the real Santa right
now stuff he's got all over
him use your eyes if I saw that I
wouldn't know what to make of it I think
it was like a toy or
something left him yep Santa's a goner
what the hell's going
on Shut
[Applause]
Up N of course they cut the
brakes oh that's a stunt car it does
have a little bit of Home Alone Vibes
sure sure Christmas Mischief chaos I
noticed here this uh broken I treay it's
broken the Peltzer smokeless
ashtray I think this can solve your
problem mhm
want the tutorial of that broken ashtray
feel like he smokless ashtray no I know
but his other ashtray is broken but
what's a smokeless ashtray what that's a
good question ashtrays don't
smoke oh
no
golly I like that she served all of them
they are a vivacious Bunch yeah I would
party with them vivacious and voracious
don't three cigarettes in the mouth any
of these Gremlins have
ID stripe is the best yeah oh my God
what is that one with the red lipstick I
need a portrait of Gremlins playing
poker oh
golly this is lowkey hilarious yeah oh
four aces look out oh you just get shot
it's is like the old west in here I also
am getting Star Wars Vibes oh gambling
Planet Dame wanders over to my table
nose like Rudolph puppets using puppets
I love
it where are all of our people remember
they have a date on Thursday yeah it's
today Thursday I hope so I hope they
have to have a date am must be Christmas
right so maybe the dates when it's all
over to end the
movie dude do you want your cigarette
lit or not you did it the first
time oh no The Flash The
Flash oh that's the key but then just
turn the lights on yeah get a flood
light get like a 2K you know Airy light
just you know barn doors open to
shineing on
[Music]
him
[Applause]
whoa what is this scene John just
complete
demolition like how did this read on the
page yeah I'm like how was this just
like a paragraph of like the Gremlins
are causing a ruckus in the bar Chris
Columbus is like and then one Bandit
Gremlin takes a gun out and shoot stor
yeah what is that don't worry about it
he's with me he's not one of them and he
is their father what's wrong why is the
car starting all right we're going to
have to make a run for it okay
jeez up in the
window great detail in this shot they've
been here too what gave it away are
these things where did they come from
where did they come from where do they
go where did they come from gr Jo the
worst thing that ever happened to me was
on
Christmas I knew this was coming Pete I
told you who's Christmas Eve I was 9
years old oh no I don't want to hear it
me and Mom were were decorating the tree
mom died bro dad never came home couple
hours went by dad wasn't home oh so the
police began a search four or five days
went by neither one of us could eat or
sleep yeah gizo was listening intently
firemen came and broke through the
chimney top and me and Mom were
expecting them to pull out a dead cat or
a bird bir and instead they pulled out
my father wow he was dressed in a Santa
Claus suant
Claus he'd been climbing down the
chimney on Christmas Eve his arms sled
with presents whoa oh my God he slipped
and broke his neck died instantly that
is extraordinarily sad and that's how I
found out there was no Santa Claus
that's why you're depressed every
Christmas I would be too woof imagine
that's how you found out there's no
Santa Claus that would be so so
confusing first you're like Mom Santa's
dead and then mom's like no actually hey
yeah we got to have two talks right now
you want the bad news or the worst news
yeah that's horrible what a story that
they just gave her back story yeah well
it's funny like you know you you mostly
Phoebe Kates gets recognized so much for
was it fast times but like that was a
really lovely little monologue right
there yeah she did very good job very
endearing in this movie she's got those
eyes that you hope that actors have that
you just like can't stop staring at you
know it's like dyed here yeah very much
the girl next door where did they all go
it'll be light soon but they're all
together some dark sleep in Heavenly
peace the audio no the audio thing where
it sounds like they're in a movie again
when they do that ah did you hear it
sound the sound like the quality of the
sound yeah
yeah let's all go to the L
I do feel bad for them though cuz not
their fault like you created them and
then you just they're inside all of
[Music]
[Applause]
them but so if they turn on the light
what will happen I've no idea yeah and
it's like is the projector light going
to there's no way these dudes know how
to how to load
film Jesus Christ Quinton Tarantino is
rolling in his grave and scorsi and all
all those guys Nolan but does scor say
you think this is a real film is it
Cinema is this
Cinema oh good flasher Gremlins at the
movies too he's getting his peeee
on snow way as a character is so
outdated yes in the future though CG in
the Rachel zegler version where's the
it's in the back of there's a boiler
room at this movie
theater
how hard do you think the script thought
like which movie should we have them
love it's a good question it seems like
all the movies chosen are like pretty
deliberate throughout
this candy yum yum I hope stripe's the
only one that makes it through other
than Gizmo Gizmo and Stripes I'm like
stripe changes his stripes goes goes for
a face turned cover your mouth don't
breathe any Gap no no no no what is he
going do with the gas they're going to
blow this place Sky High cuz of light I
feel like there's so many other ways to
do it could you just turn on the lights
well they're going to turn on the lights
all right they're going to light this
place
up it's like a monster
movie oh nice
egg cool shots whoa coming right through
the Silver
[Music]
Screen
nice come
on it's like Westside Story all of a
sudden one of your own
kind
oh not a mask on oh my god did he have
to blow up the whole theater how are
people in town going to engage with the
art of Cinema now
stripe
uhoh a stripe of glitter in his hair
tinsel looks
like wow Billy just doesn't give a
what he's destroying yeah you could have
walked under that candy sign saved them
having to buy a new fluorescent or neon
whatever you call that take thisiss go
back and try and find some kind of light
switch oh oh yeah oh really cute
onscreen kiss what a first
date nicely done Saturday at 8:30 we'll
have Santa Claus bug bunny Sylvester and
ET he was behind ET a Easter egg ET
found
[Music]
home oh asash BOS
whoa damn dude
[Music]
gmsa getaway ride he's kind of funny he
is
funny yes
[Music]
ow
woof got a good arm on
stripe light it's the light oh no is
Gizmo about to make a sacrifice Miss
American
Pie no
[Music]
ow wow what is that Merry Christmas you
filthy
animal oh put him in the light oh no
it's a perfect little saw for him it's
perfect
[Music]
size
the Barbie Corvette I'm so scared he's
going to be in the light
[Music]
though oh that bat's not going to hold
out much
longer damn ow that looked
real no Gizmo hide Garfield shirts
nice my
eyes good call well done
the water
no water gun guns it's like the electric
company water gun water gun Let's Go
[Music]
Gizmo a great POV I mean they have
gotten so much of grou from Gizmo right
it does feel that way dude like I guess
this is after Star Wars but noises but
yeah it's like the look of Yoda with
everything else yeah exactly exactly
totally my
pression B oh my God he's going in the
water
Bly
[Music]
who all he's evil yeah
I thought we could fix him nah he likes
guns too much he's all about this life I
feel like the water's getting on him now
yeah why isn't it working Gremlin is a
good title for this movie I wonder if
it's not really water it's like olive
oil or
something no it's
working oh come on buddy eyes are about
to pop out of your
[Music]
head
no
oh good it's the most realistic car jump
stunt the thing's totaled now giz
Mo oh yeah oh no oh poor
[Music]
guy oh damn what happens when it's sun
and water at the same time this
[Music]
oh damn that's icky so
cool
dad your scarf
a dad asks no questions now yeah you
will find the Babe wrapped in swaddling
clothes lying in a wrecked Garden Center
in a hardware
store
wow you good job oh groy that was gnarly
like deflated that was disgusting good
job with that cool effects in this movie
yeah don't you I bet he'd like some
chicken
soup no no hey I was wondering if you
would show back up me too gentleman who
sold me the M he did not sell it to
[Music]
you a they understand each other your
Society has done with all of Nature's
gifts oh you are not ready
a I mean he's got a point I guess yeah
he does but also like harsh he has
something to say to you
OT Want to Say Goodbye perhaps someday
you may be ready until then McKai will
be waiting a you'll be ready in no time
Billy well that's a story so if your air
conditioner goes go on the fritz or your
washing machine oh lovely before you
call the repairman turn on all the
lights check all the closets and
cupboards look under all the beds cuz
you never can tell with Gremlins might
be a gremlin in your
house whoa crus just popped right
up really cute
nice that was lovely that was so much
fun Mar balls Miss reject Nation you
know what the funny thing is I already
owned this product before agreeing to do
this partnership I could have used my
influencer ring to get it for free or at
a discount but hey now you can get it at
a discount cuz this week we are of
course sponsored by manscape as a
married man who's always on the move I
value looking sharp all keeping things
efficient and that's where manscapes
performance package 5.0 Ultra comes in
featuring the lawn mower 5.0 and it is a
game changer the package is honestly a
perfect gift for yourself or for another
man that you might know I'll give this
to John if anyone ask I pay for it out
of my own pocket no seriously this is
easily the best because it comes with
not one but two NextGen blade heads see
the difference it's good thing I have
two now for demonstration purposes so
you got the standard trimmer for a
perfect neat trim but this one the new
foil blade for that super smooth finish
and oh yeah it's all about safe grouping
with their Advanced Skin safe technology
plus they're waterproof so no more
crumbs on the carpet the package also
includes The Weedwacker 2.0 for ear and
nose and I definitely use this because
look at me I'm a hairy guy and the must
have liquid formation the crop Soother
aftershave lotion and the crop preserver
ball deodorant say goodbye to post shave
irritation and hello freshness and the
ultimate cherry on top two free gifts
manscapes premium boxers 2.0 and the
2.0 toiletry bag again I already
have one the boxers I'm wearing my here
right now and the bag is perfect for all
your grooming Essentials as you can see
so you ready to elevate your grooming
game head to manscape.com and use code
rejects for a cool 20% off plus free
shipping remember it's rejects for 20%
off at manscape.com let's get those
jingle balls holiday ready with manscape
thank you to Shopify for sponsoring
which is what we use for our merch store
and is our gamechanging partner in
e-commerce so whether you're launching a
passion project or scaling to new
heights Shopify is e-commerce Powerhouse
guing you at every step from creating
your first online store to opening
physical locations Shopify makes it
seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and in store sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on our journey
using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying
sales to scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us owers 10%
of us e-commerce backing businesses big
and small in over 175 countries there
are war-winning support always there to
guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com rejects
all overc case shopify.com rejects start
your Shopify success story now let's
grow together with Shopify team super
into that God what a cast too what would
you say the genre of that film
was that's a good question I mean it's
definitely like a mish mash it's
definitely got you know horror comedy
family
holiday like you know it's not hoe
mandal what says who special vocal
effects Frank Welker fun oh yeah okay
there you go yeah you got a bunch of
like voice actors to do at least I'm
sure mwai had
others but yeah yeah yeah like this is
one of those it's like it's a horror
comedy but it's also like you could
watch this with your family like it's I
feel like you know kids there's nothing
too harsh or crazy that would would
either freak or scar freak out or scar
like a kid and there's nothing too adult
really happening so like yeah it's like
a family horror comedy
holiday something or other this is a
weird question but like what do you feel
like the lesson of the movie
is like it's a cautionary
tale I mean I guess so cuz at the
beginning you know it's uh dad's not
taking no for an answer and he's like I
must have this like I guess it's that
thing of like um assuming that you can
just is with enough money that you
should just be able to have anything you
want and that's the funny part because
they didn't have money but he spent $200
you know yeah which in the moment seemed
like he was like I'll give you you know
money is no is is uh is No Object but
yeah then we know they're hurting so I
don't know I think it's maybe about uh
respecting nature
something yeah like the lesson at the
end like you think that you knew what
you were doing and you don't yeah your
Society is always doing this
yeah yeah out of it you're always kind
of perverting and exacerbating the
things that are laid out for your
abundance by Nature you know and not
leaving well enough alone Peter Gabriel
I love him you know some the one of the
most impressive parts to me was the
music I thought that they just did an
excellent excellent job with the music
in this oh yeah yeah cuz it's like
endearing and and sweet when it needs to
be and then it's like bouncy and
demented when it needs to be and it all
kind of feels appropriately within the
spirit of the holiday and all
that yeah I'm into this yeah me too I
mean I like them I enjoy and I think
they're kind of rare now these
experiences where you watch you're like
what genre is the like this is so many
things all at once and it's I think that
helps make it unique now I'm super
curious about the second one if it's
more of a comedy or more of a horror
from the vague things I've heard people
joke about it it seems like it's like
more zany more comedy as my guess but I
don't know I'm sure they'll incorporate
some level of horror in some way or
another is there a world in which you
add this to your Christmas rotation yeah
actually I would say definitely like CU
for me got laughter because for me like
you know I uh am certainly a yearround
horror fan um and I think this is nice
this is like a good like November or
early December kind of move inter your
video yes I was going to let him finish
the sentence but I didn't you know what
else is good what a brand new t-shirt or
hoodie or whatever you like from reject
naations shop.com we got so many great
designs new ones dropping all the time
we got this brand new America's ass the
boys inspired tea we got the snip snip
and the aot to Star Wars inspired the
who influences the influencers the Child
Protection Services space babies of the
Galaxy that's the perfect shirt for a
Gremlins rewatch all right these are
easily space babies of some Galaxy can I
tell you something cool what did you
what was that I just got my first reject
shirt oh what is what did you get what
did you get what you get it is just I
wanted a classic I just wanted reject
because it felt like a reject my whole
life and so it's just a white te plain
white te reject baby yeah get yourself
one get yourself one get you one but you
get get yourself get yourself get
yourself that might be on a short one
day it's the best way to support the
channel it's our favorite way to support
the channel and and yeah we got signs
designed in house we also got some
licensed ones too so go over there check
it out and uh hey if you happen to grab
something send us a picture tag Us in it
and we'll repost you send us a picture
pick I like it but anyhow
Gremlin what were we talking about uh if
you were going to add this to your
rotation yeah I mean for me this is like
the perfect like November or early
December kind of movie where you know
like cuz I'm why November because it's
not like it's a Christmas movie but it's
not so much a Christmas movie that it's
like about uh it's not solely being a
Christmas movie about Christmas things
first and foremost I guess is why so
like this is a a a fun Christmas based
adventure and it feels like Christmas
time and there are you know warm notes
um there's certainly warmth from the
family and there's warmth from like the
developing relationship between Billy
and uh the the Phoebe Kate's character
and stuff like that and it hearkens to a
lot of Christmas movies but it's not
necessarily uh you know the spirit of
Christmas as you're saying that I
remember that there's that debate you
know how I mean it's been put to bed but
like is Die Hard a Christmas movie
there's that debate I've heard that with
Gremlins too is it a is it a Christmas
movie and like to me this clearly was a
Christmas movie but I do get what you're
saying it's it's a Christmas movie
without like Christmas themes it's just
at Christmas time like it starts with
the Christmas present but I don't feel
like the theme was like family is more
important than any you know but then we
do hear that story from pH K's character
Yeah Christmas the that was a striking
little piece of tragedy right that feels
like that could be its own movie yes oh
my God different tone yeah very yeah I
mean that's kind of the nice thing is I
feel like this has a lot of Christmas
spirit in it kind of around the
periphery and stuff like that because
yeah it's like everybody is just trying
to deal with the holiday in one way or
another you've got yeah your people who
are in the spirit you've got your people
who are like they touch on that and I
think that's kind of a nice thing for a
movie like this because it's it's a a
real thing that they didn't have to do
that whole discussion of like people get
really depressed around the holidays and
not everybody is in you know the spirit
and and here's might be why and then
taking the time to give that character
that backstory and that monologue for uh
Phoebe Kates which was really touching
and even the way they draw the family
it's like you could have
had conflict or or just like I don't
know other tensions and it's like you
know the the main family like they they
love each other and there's not like a
huge like I feel like his inventions in
a different movie might have like ca
been a big source of tension and they're
just like a quirky detail and like you
pointed out it's like the mom she really
loves him and she's kind of amused by
his wacky little inventions and stuff
and there's like a lot of warmth there
for the family you get to choose how you
feel about things sometimes and like
they just kind of the sun too like he's
so excited with the present and he loves
his dad and even when at the bank
somebody calls out like your dad's a
loser never whatever like they are a
tight family unit so maybe it is more
about family than I'm even letting on
but like it is I think that's really
sweet we always see the mo the wife
that's so annoyed with her bumbling
husband you know like kind of like the
Marge Simpson Homer Simpson issue and
like this was like I felt the genuine
love between the dog the parents the kid
like and when they walk in it's not like
why is the sword keep falling or like oh
this orange juice it's just kind of like
what it is uh I am curious what happened
to Cory's character he did kind of just
trickle this is another this is another
interesting I feel like movies were also
kind of poised differently in previous
decades where like this had that an also
a quality I don't even know quite how to
describe it where you have your main
characters that you're kind of always
with and you have some distinct Side
characters who you peer in on but who
aren't like the points so yeah they
don't all get like wrapped up it's like
you know Mr futterman doesn't really get
like a big wrapup and Cory Feldman
doesn't get like a big wrapup or
something like they're mentioned and
they pop up and like you know Cory's on
the radio at one point I think that's
the last we hear of him um and things
like that yeah like I can understand
wanting some resolution on them but at
the same time good enough it didn't
bother me too much it's just interesting
yeah because like the situation resolves
with our main characters in a very
sensible way and then I I I appreciate
the way it handles the rest of them
because it almost does feel like just
bumping into people around town in a
small place where everybody sort of
knows each other sometimes you want to
go where everybody knows your name see I
usually finish it but you didn't on that
Sor right I got to watch more cheers I'm
sorry you haven't seen cheers I've seen
like scattered episodes but not enough
to be like I have binged it and know all
the I don't know the theme song by heart
obviously you're sitting with the Boston
girl though you know that right sorry by
the next time we hang out and and I'll
have seen cheers blasphemy and I'll go
to Fenway pack I did think that the guy
the um bumbling drunk guy he definitely
had a Boston accent not a New York
accent I was thinking that for a minute
but I was like okay some Boston people
move over neighbor yeah Mr fman Dick
Miller yeah he definitely sounded very
Boston in this for some reason yeah he's
got one of those like in yeah east coast
East Coast indeterminate accent totally
CU certain words I was like where are we
again but yeah I thought this was really
like for a movie that came out in 1984
that you and I have heard about our
entire lives that's been probably hyped
up by everybody we know that like
definitely obviously technology changing
to the extent that it has for me to be
like well I really enjoyed myself during
that yeah I'm pretty excited that that
was the the takeaway oh yeah like this I
can absolutely see the love that this
has has garnered over the years and this
does have again a slightly different
sensibility than the here and now and it
definitely feels like something more
akin to like the time that like an ET
comes out or something where yeah it
starts out kind of fun and fanciful and
then becomes like a serious situation
after a while and it doesn't lose its
sense of fun and fancy but it does
become much more of like a horror movie
by then it also felt like a Steven
Spielberg produced film yeah and it also
felt like it borrowed from a lot of
Classics like of Oz type with the witch
but also a lot of currents borrow from
this oh 100% this this is funny and it
was it was interesting to watch as they
there were a lot of things and I'm sure
there are more than I'm going to
remember but there are a lot of ways in
which I feel like they were homaging
Christmas movies because it's like he
works at the Savings and Loan and
they're watching you know it's a
wonderful at one point but and Mrs
deagle is clearly Scrooge SL also Mr
Potter um and yeah you you have these
other little touchstones to various
Christmas movies and iconography and
stuff like that uh in ways that I
thought were if it was now they would be
more like inyour face like see huh
reference huh whereas here like they
happen and you can catch them and you
can go like hey that's fun but they're
not like screaming they felt a little
bit more subtle and a little bit more
sort of and same thing with the
Christmas music like sprinkled in but
not all the time and like even when it
was there it was kind of like a Twist of
variation on it yeah for sure yeah it's
not like beating you in the face with it
and it's like I liked uh the effects I
really thought that the way that they
chose to you know they they props to Joe
Dante and i' I've seen a couple of his
movies uh namely I mean Small Soldiers
certainly kind of hearkens to this and
uh I really like the way that they shot
the M the Gremlins because there's so
many moments where you're like okay
great use of like offscreen elements and
camera movements uh to hide the things
that are especially hard to achieve with
either stop motion or puppetry but then
there is a bunch of puppetry and there's
a bunch of stop motion animation or at
least here and there for some of the
more complex moments there stop motion
animation and I thought it Blended all
those things together in a really really
nice smooth sort of way I agree and I
don't mean this um in any way that like
I know that people don't like this word
sometimes I thought it was really cute
the way that it all Blended together
like I thought that the mwai was very
cute and um I even thought that the that
the um gremlins like when they're all
marching towards us and and you were
like oh that stop motion of the all of
them like coming toward I thought it was
endearing and cute yeah they're zany and
wacky and kind of cute and kind of cute
yeah totally I'm into this yeah me too I
like this a whole lot yeah this was this
was kind of everything I I hoped it
could be and nice to have that
experience where you're like I don't
quite quite know what this is yeah we
were like an hour in and I said D what's
the genre yeah and and it just keeps
kind of twisting and and warping and and
yeah it's it's Unique it's very unique
in that way and I appreciate that quite
a bit like yeah I'll definitely pull
this out year year after year during the
holidays I would be curious to see the
second one so you guys if you want to
see us do that like comment subscribe
don't forget to tell your friends we
just watched Gremlins for the first time
maybe they haven't seen it holiday
season's a good time to do a nice watch
along with us any final Gremlins
thoughts um I feel like we touched on
most everything I like the cast uh
thought the cast was all very Charming
everybody you know was very Earnest in
their different roles good again the
main cast I thought was really nice good
character actor work popping up and
everything and a solid script as well
okay I thought this was a solidly made
picture all around we might be the
rejects but we don't reject this not at
all we accept it we accept it you got to
change your hat then I except yes yeah
dropping next month get your accept hat
from on the back side should be there so
you can kind of flip the reversible yeah
you flip it inside out A Nightmare
Before Christmas his face yeah the mayor
he'll be just like that that's another
great like November or early December
movie where it's like for partway but
also October yeah sure do not do not
come at me right now with Nightmare
Before Christmas is not a full-blown
Halloween movie it is I don't watch it
during Halloween time but I don't
begrudge anybody who does I also think
it's a Christmas movie but it's not not
a Halloween movie it is it is a
Halloween movie that's a debate for a
different time thanks for being here
with us we'll see you soon love you
[Music]
all